all right guys
bang bang i've got a special treat for
you today
i have a 12 year old on the podcast
which
uh is not probably what anyone is
expecting but i've got uh
zach here with me thanks for doing this
man no thank you for getting me like
twitter famous i guess
so let's start with this uh you live in
the uk
right yeah all right and
what do you do all day because uh you've
got these youtube videos that you upload
all about investing and companies where
does that interest come from or when did
you start looking at
things in finance and business yeah it's
just like you know i i
you know when you're on youtube and
stuff you always get a load of adverts
and like my like my broker at the moment
running a massive advertising campaign
one time
as everywhere and i just thought i put
four like 40 quid into it
just here see how it went originally i
just started doing like the uk
stock market and stuff that didn't go
too well as a uk somewhat
it's not like it's not as good as us
it's not as it's
takes so long it's been taking longer to
recover from the coronavirus it hasn't
like bounced back like the u.s stock
market
so i started doing us shares i just
started building up from there
i mean i've seen it all i went at my
peak i've been up like 70
on my portfolio literally it was like it
went
all the way down to like one percent
loss it's going all the way back up to
65 percent uh
you know it's like i've just like seen
it all now
so okay so you've got a uh a portfolio
that you're
uh looking after right and
what are your friends doing so at 12
years old i was not talking about
business i was not talking about
investing
i basically was trying as hard as i
could to not have my mom find out all
the dumb things i was doing
uh where does your interest in kind of
business and investing come from
they're like well i got my friends into
investing he only invests a little bit
and he yeah he's he's a kind of into it
he
thinks he thinks it's quite fun i think
he just wants to get his money for his
new um
ps4 at the moment so i can't see people
having a good idea
yeah like like with my friends i don't
really talk about it that much if you
just like mess around and stuff
absolutely and so talk about these
videos you've been putting on youtube
right so
a friend of mine jim o'shaughnessy sent
me uh a link and he said hey look at
this guy
and uh basically you've got videos where
you sit in front of the camera
and you talk about various investment
opportunities or companies
how do you film the videos do your
parents help you do you do it all
yourself how does that work
no i just i just filmed it with my
little my little crummy little tablet
because my old tablet i had it for like
seven years
it ran out and i i decided i didn't want
to buy the new apple ones i was like
i better put in socks instead make get
the apple once i made some money and
start
and i got into youtube i was like oh
this is what you get for buying a 60
pound tablet with the camera footage
but yeah so usually just use my dad's
but yeah it's been pretty good
okay and so when you're doing this um
how do you research for the videos or
where does the information come from do
you spend all day reading like
like you're pretty informed it's not
like you know you're just saying random
things so
how do you look at acquiring the
information or learning
yeah so like with most some a lot of my
videos it's already sucks already own
i just talk about those kind of stocks i
mean i mean a lot of these videos these
are just being companies i've been just
reading about
watching interviews about you know
watching clips from you know reading
invested presentations like
three weeks before that and then i just
think i'll just upload
upload it onto my youtube channel it's
like my latest one
ipob which is one of the tremendous ones
merging both
i had researched that for about a week
before that watch some interviews on
cnbc
and yeah that's then i just thought i
might as well make a video about it
so literally for the ipob video that you
made you researched for almost a week
and basically just consumed as much
content as you possibly could
and then you create the video saying you
know here's what's going on and here are
my thoughts yeah basically
yeah that's awesome so all right let's
talk about what happened the other night
so you basically uh it looks like you
had been using twitter to try to
distribute the videos
um and also reach out to people and say
you know hey chamath or others
uh will you allow me to interview you or
will you check out my videos right
yeah all right and so chamath responded
to you maybe
uh he didn't know what was going on at
first and then eventually said you know
if your parents basically sign off
on doing something like i'll help you
out on your youtube channel right
yeah it is quite interesting because he
said that but he didn't leave an
email for us in an email so who doesn't
getting out of there or something but i
like traffic
i'll give you his email and uh and then
that's part of the challenge i think is
that you gotta go find the email to see
how resourceful you are
yeah scrolling for a list of different
ones
okay and so that happens and so uh jim
and uh a couple of other people
basically said hey this kid's pretty
smart like we should see if we can help
him out a little bit
um and so when jim sent me the uh the
link to your twitter and to your youtube
i said you know what like let me just
fire off a tweet jim had already tweeted
it
and i actually didn't know how many
people would go follow you but i
said let's see what happens and i
figured you were sleeping when all this
was going on right
okay uh and so i told paulina my wife i
said uh you know i'm gonna tweet it and
maybe he wakes up to some more followers
but like let's see
um and within a couple of minutes of
tweeting it i was like uh-oh
he's gonna wake up to a lot more
followers what was your reaction when
you woke up
well it's just like oh that's good isn't
it got a lot of followers now
initially i thought somebody just
initially i thought some of my youtube
channel just brought some books and
stuff
what you thought what happened like they
had brought sub bots you know the uk
my fake followers and stuff i thought so
just brought me a little fake followers
[Music]
okay so when you woke up you went to
sleep you had like 18 or 20 followers
and you woke up to what 10
000. um i think it's like eight seven
thousand when i woke up
and it was like every half an hour i was
gaining another hundred followers
it's pretty crazy i mean i turn my phone
on in the morning it's just like a
constant stream of alerts coming from
had to silence everything
that's awesome and what how many
followers are you up to now
it's kind of steadied out now it's kind
of city at around 90
500 okay so if we get you to 20
000 then that'll be a big win from from
uh 18 to 20
000 18 followers to 20 000 followers
would be pretty big jump for you right
yeah it's like when you when you compare
it to like how many people there are you
know
just few from my school that's for like
a thousand people my school is like
18 times as many as that follow me on
twitter it's a bit crazy when you think
about it
for sure and what did your parents say
when uh when you told them that uh you
had 20 000 followers on twitter do they
do they understand what that means yeah
yeah my heart's like
pretty up today they're like oh wow
that's pretty good how did that happen
i love it and so what's the plan now
you're gonna keep creating videos
and and you'll tweet them out or what
are you kind of planning to do
yeah certainly it's just about you know
making videos and then you know when i
do
when i'm in a bit of research i kind of
just tweet that on twitter
got it so you're 12 what else do you
spend your time doing right
your mom was here earlier so everyone
who's listening uh
i made sure that his mom was fine with
us uh talking and stuff but
what do you spend your time doing
outside of uh investing do you go and
play at the playground with your friends
do you
uh go to school do you read like what
else are you doing
yeah so i go to school yeah yeah that's
good you got to see yeah
yeah oh yeah i meet up with my friends
you know we mess around you know
have fun go out to the park sometimes
around their house so yeah
i do i do that outside and you know when
i get home
i don't know i'm not like i'm not one of
those people who immediately when i go
home it's like
oh well it's like well as soon as i get
outside school get it's like
see how the stocks are doing then walk
over my mate
then get over and then and then just you
know
um just do normal stuff i guess like
so when when school ends the first thing
you do is you check your stocks
yeah first thing i love it
uh what what are your favorite uh stocks
right now just in terms of the ones that
you've covered and created videos on are
there ones that specifically you're
paying attention to
yeah so like um my biggest position at
the moment is a stock called arkamoto
it's quite it used to be a penny stock
it went up 68
in one day i mean about 168 percent on
that
so yes i sold half of my position you
know and whatever
what i'm gonna left all the profits into
it so i won't take some risk off the
table
but what is that what does that company
do oh so they produce freewheel
ev vehicles and you and you know i like
the ceo
you know the vision's pretty good you
know it's backed by sandy monroe
um he's going to help them scale up like
50 000 vehicles a year
company at the time i invested in it was
worth 150 million that was going to
quite something like
700 million in revenue in four years so
i just feel like this companies might i
might as well take a bet on this it's
what's it so like my average is five
dollars and 91 cents that's 16 now
so yeah i mean but that's in a sense
that's parts if you just
run up in eevee in general i mean after
your lecture
seemed quite nice bounce back in the um
really the whole stock market
awesome and so when you think of your
portfolio
is it 100 stocks do you have other
things other than just kind of
uh public equities how do you think
about investing
yeah so when you when you live in the uk
it's slightly different so
at the moment it's all stock so i've got
some spare cash traffic sold out of the
name position
you know half of it so i would say i
probably look at like i mean i don't
know
like five percent into bitcoin is like
the crypto thing
um and then just put the rest back into
maybe ipob or something which
i'll have a lesser position got it so
you're uh
a believer in bitcoin yeah i think it's
like
well i was i tweeted this earlier it's
like there's 21 million bitcoins in the
world
you know loads of them are lost and then
and then you look at obviously this
the price point was like 18 000 now it's
quite up there but
when you look at it it's like a
decentralized currency you know it's not
controlled by the government's it's not
controlled by anyone
that's really six-sided governments
don't like it but you know people like
like it's not it's not controlled by
anyone
and it's really in the hands of the
people got it
and when you think about your portfolio
uh are you you mentioned earlier you're
rebalancing you're kind of
treating this just like any other uh
kind of hedge fund manager
or professional investor would do right
yeah i guess so
and where did you learn how to do that
you know it's like um i just really like
taught myself you know watch some
youtube videos
at the start i uh initially i was
telling you nothing about investing at
the start you know
none of my parents are traders or
anything nobody in my family was
and so i did i originally i just brought
you know when you kind of get an idea of
who like everyone's famous
so i just put some money into some of
the famous companies
i just learned from there i mean i think
one of the one of the first holdings in
portfolio was berkshire hathaway
it's like within one week i realized
that all warren buffett invested in food
companies and airlines you're selling
out of
so i sold that put it into some uk's the
hawks
told that and finally found us stocks
and that was
i started making the returns from there
got it
and when did you start doing this was
this something where like when the virus
um came around and the pandemic hit
that's when you started or were you
doing this before the pandemic
i'd say when the pandemic hit i
unfortunate i didn't start when it was
middle of the stock market crash
i would have made a whole lot of money
then i started around like four or five
months ago i'd say
got it and what platform do you use to
trade on do you use one of the like
uh new technology platforms or you use
like a traditional brokerage account
yeah so in the uk robinhood was going to
be here but they decided not to launch
so i used basically the uk version of
robinhood at the moment trading too
they're like zero commission all that
but obviously like the one problem is
just like financial exchange impact so
you might be up
like one percent on stock but you're
down on it because of the currency
difference
but then at the same time i'm not going
to pay like 10 percent of all the money
to stop for one trade and a traditional
brokerage account so it works out pretty
well
zach you realize how ridiculous it feels
for me to be talking to somebody who's
12 years old and understands
uh the foreign currency risk and the
exchange
risk that you're taking right yeah
all right so you're uh it looks like
you're in your bedroom
is that the headquarters of the zac cox
trading uh business yeah i do more or
less
everything in here you know it's all on
the it's all on the phone which
i'm using now all the trades happen on
there okay
you do everything on your phone yeah all
of it on my phone
what a legend uh and is it just you or
do you
uh have anybody else who's helping you
are you gonna plan
to uh get more of your friends in what's
kind of the plan for the future
yeah well like i don't really have
anyone who's helping me i actually got
my dad
into it recently i showed him how that
was rodney i was making he was like oh i
can do this and my son's doing it
but yeah sorry i didn't hit into it but
yeah i think
like in the future it's not really like
necessarily persuading people though i
might put my link on my twitter page and
try and get some free
free shares i got a snapchat free share
didn't hold it and then it ran up 100
so i just sold it and played it to some
company which i made lost like
one pound on i think if i get the
snapchat show i would have made double
money on it
so that was a pretty good free show but
i mean i might put on my twitter or
something get some free chats that's
always good
gotcha i love it all right so you're
12 years old now i want to document this
because you're obviously incredibly
intelligent and ambitious
what do you want to do with your life
right if we come back and we watch this
video
30 years from now what are you hoping to
have accomplished by then like i would
say in like 30 years like
maybe be a fun manager that's like the
hope maybe
one of the smaller fire managers manage
like five million dollars or something
you know that'd be pretty good you know
being a manager um
getting getting the nice pay package it
comes with it
sorry did you just say that maybe be a
small fun manager with like five billion
dollars
no i didn't say that but yeah that'd be
pretty cool five million dollars
i love it all right any last words for
everyone um we're gonna send it we're
gonna link to your youtube in the
description so everyone
that's uh listening to this or watching
it on youtube go check out zach's
youtube page
uh he's literally smarter than 90 of the
idiots on twitter
uh so he's doing a pretty good job but
anything you want to say to everyone
yeah just like um if he says if you
subscribe to my youtube channel i'd like
greatly appreciate it
and keep on investing all right so we're
going to send people to your youtube
we're going to send people to twitter
and uh if they have questions if they
tweet at you you're pretty active on
twitter now right so you'll you'll try
your best to answer everybody
yeah awesome man all right listen thank
you so much for doing this
you are uh you're a legend in the making
my friend so this is gonna be fun
yeah hopefully i'm sure it will be